PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to beyond
payments with Android Pay.
I'm Prakash Hariramani,
Group Product Manager
on the Android Pay team.
And with me is--
MAX KRISTOF: Max Kristof.
I lead the Android
Pay engineering team.
It's great to be here today.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So as
you saw in the last session,
for those of you who were here
for Android Pay Everywhere,
Android Pay is not
just about payments.
It's about enhancing the
entire in-store experience.
Sending your card,
your payment card
to the merchant or retailer
was just the first step,
but there's more
to it than that.
When I go and make a
purchase in-store typically,
in addition to my
payment card, I also
enter a loyalty card, a
gift card, and/or an offer.
And that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So we're going to talk about
three key stakeholders today--
users, merchants,
and issuers or banks.
Now for users we're
going to show you
how users can go beyond
payments, how easy it's
going to be for them
to sign up for loyalty,
and most importantly,
use it in the middle
of an in-store experience
when they need it most.
For merchants, we're
going to show you
how they can engage with
their customers, how they can
contextually send
them reminders,
and most importantly,
Max is going
to show you how easy it is
for merchants or developers
to add the functionality
to their apps.
And then finally we're going
to talk about issuers or banks.
We're going to show how easy it
is for banks to bring Android
Pay functionality to
their apps so they
can connect with their card
holders through their channels.
So let's first start
with the pain points--
what are we trying
to solve here?
So the average US household
has about 22-ish loyalty cards,
but less than 45% are active.
Only about 10 are active.
That's pretty bad, right?
It's bad for users because
you spend all this time
signing up for that membership.
You fill out this long form, and
then you're standing in store
and you don't have
it when you need it.
You want to save money.
You want to get points.
And it's not there with you.
It's also bad for merchants.
They're spending
millions and putting
in a lot of effort trying to
engage with their customers.
Continuing with pain
points, less than 1%
of all coupons or offers that
are issued today are redeemed.
That's pretty staggering.
That's pretty bad too.
And why?
So it's bad for
users because they
are unable to save money, again,
when they're in line, in-store,
for a purchase because they've
forgotten to cut the coupon,
clip it, bring it with them
in the store and then eat it.
And it's bad for merchants.
Millions of dollars
are spent every year
by manufacturers and retailers
to bring these offers
in front of users.
So first we're going to
talk about users and how
we address these pain points.
So fundamentally,
there's two things
that users are looking for--
saving time and saving money.
So there's many things
Android Pay does to save time.
First, during payment, you just
have to unlock your phone, tap,
and you're done.
You do not have
to launch any app.
You don't have to have the
app running in the foreground.
You just set it up
once, and you tap.
And the most important
thing is it doesn't just
send your payment credential.
So as Pali showed in
the previous demo, when
he tapped on the
Walgreens terminal,
it sent his Balance Rewards
loyalty card and his payment
card.
And that does save
time because I
don't have to fumble in my
wallet, find that loyalty card,
find that offer, and then
present it to the cashier.
Saving money is the
other thing users desire.
So the best way to
demonstrate this
is actually to walk
through a few demos.
So for those of you who were
in the previous session,
Pali saved money with his
Walgreens Balance Rewards card.
He bought a pack of almonds.
He saved $2.00.
I would also like to save money.
s before I can do that, I
need to add my Balance Rewards
card to Android Pay.
So to talk through
this demo, I'm
going to invite Kate
Paduchowski, who's
Senior Product Manager from
Walgreens, up on stage.
Welcome, Kate.
KATE PADUCHOWSKI:
Thanks, Prakash.
It's really great to be here.
We're really excited
to have the opportunity
to team up with Android Pay
to introduce this new loyalty
experience to our Android users.
We cannot wait to share the
Save to Android Pay e-mail
to our loyalty users who will
be able to take advantage
of our simple message--
tap, tap, done.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Excellent.
So let's see this in action.
Can we cast this please?
Great.
So here's my email.
I'm a Balance Rewards member,
and I got this from Walgreens.
I'm just going to hit
Save to Android Pay,
and it's going to show me a
preview of my Balance Rewards
card.
I'm going to confirm
it, and I'm done.
It's that simple.
So now when I go
into my Android Pay,
I can see not just my AmEx card
but also my Walgreens Balance
Rewards.
It's that simple.
Now when I go and make
a purchase at Walgreens,
I don't even have to
remember anything.
I just tap once.
It sends the payment.
Tap again, it sends a
loyalty card, and I'm done.
Tap, tap, done.
KATE PADUCHOWSKI: Exactly.
We're really excited
that Android Pay can
make it so easy for our users to
sign up for our Balance Rewards
program.
Now even more customers
can save and earn points
as they shop at Walgreens.
Android Pay and Walgreens will
be the first payment solution
and retailer to launch
instant loyalty enrollment.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Thank you again Kate.
We're delighted to have
you here and delighted
with our partnership
with Walgreens.
KATE PADUCHOWSKI: Thanks.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So
let's switch use cases.
So that was a retailer use
case, an in-store experience.
I want to talk about another
use case I'm very excited about,
which is in-store dining.
So what we're
going to do is show
how Android Pay can
go beyond payments
for an immersive
dining experience.
And you're going to do
that through Ziosks.
So you see these
Android tablets here.
They are by Ziosk, which have
these Android touchscreen
tablets.
And you can find these actually
on Chili's restaurants today.
So to talk through
this demo, I'm
going to invite Viren
Balar, who is the CTO
and co-founder of the Ziosk.
And I also want to
acknowledge Wade Allen-- Wade,
can you wave your hand?
He's the vice president
of digital innovation
at Chili's-- a great leader in
innovation and we're thrilled
to partner with you.
VIREN BALAR: Thank you, Prakash.
Hi, everyone.
So at Ziosk, our mission
is to revolutionize
dining experience.
And by partnering
with Android Pay,
we're able to bring our
brick and mortar restaurant
partners into the digital age.
And Chili's is a perfect
launch partner for us
because they really understand
the value of digital
in revolutionizing
dining experience
for the guest on the table.
Today, we're going to
demo some use cases
that are core
functionality on Ziosk
and how this is all
simplified with Android Pay
even better than what
it is today, right?
So prior to Ziosk, if
you went to Chili's, you
would have to fill out
this E-Club-- first name,
last name, email address, zip
code-- pretty lengthy, pretty
inefficient as well.
And then you would
have to give it
to the wait staff who would
put it in their pocket,
and maybe it'll make
it to the manager.
And maybe he will enter it
into their database system.
It's not real time, right?
It's very inefficient.
So when we launched Ziosk,
services at Ziosk we started
enrolling for the loyalty
programs at Chili's.
And we see enrollment
go up by 10 times.
It's a pretty staggering number.
So when we do the
demo, you'll see how
easy is it with Android Pay.
It's going to be even simpler
than what we have done today,
which is live in
the restaurants.
So Prakash, you want
to see a demo of how
to join a loyalty program?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: That
sounds great, Viren.
So if we could just focus on
the terminal on the right.
So I'm sitting at Chili's.
So the setting is I'm sitting
at Chili's at the table
ready to order my food.
And on this Ziosk
terminal, I see
an option to join the My
Chili's Rewards program.
So I'm lazy.
I'm not going to
fill out this form,
so I'm just going
to hit Join Now.
And all I have to do, as you can
see, is I'm just going to tap--
and as a security feature,
I will authenticate.
OK, so we're going to tap.
And as you can see, it sent my
information from Android Pay,
and it's asking for
my consent to send
my first name, last
name, email address.
So I don't have to do
any kind of typing,
and I just can continue.
So I've given consent for
this information to be sent
to Chili's.
So now you're seeing
the Chili's site.
And all I have to do
is just enter a PIN,
and I'm registered.
So now I have a My Chili's
Rewards loyalty card.
And I'm just going to
save to Android Pay.
And there you go.
VIREN BALAR: It's always there.
You don't have to worry
about forgetting it anymore.
So you want to log in now?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Sure.
So now I've signed
up for loyalty.
And now I'm going
to login because I
want Chili's to know I'm
sitting at the restaurant
and I want them
to know who I am.
So I'm just going to hit Login,
and then I'm just going to tap.
[CHIME]
VIREN BALAR: Boom.
You got 60 points.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
I have 60 points,
and I'm getting a
little bit hungry.
I did skip lunch today.
VIREN BALAR: Yep.
So let's order some-- what
can we buy for your 60 points?
Maybe a couple of bowls
of chips and salsa?
Won't be enough for
everybody, but I
think you and I can
definitely hog them up.
All right, so we're
going to order that.
We're going to add one plate.
We're going to share that.
We're going to send the order,
and have this feeling something
amazing is going to happen.
Click Yes.
Order is going in the
kitchen-- I just confirmed it.
And boom-- it shows up.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Oh my god.
VIREN BALAR: Max,
you're amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Instant
enrollment, instant chips--
life doesn't get any better.
By the way, I should
have mentioned
that if you see anything
that excites you
during this presentation, feel
free to applaud at any time.
VIREN BALAR: Exactly.
So Prakash, now we have to
show the payment piece of it.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Oh,
so you're looking at me.
You want me to pay now?
VIREN BALAR: Yeah, I know.
That's why I reminded you.
So one of the most
important things
that Ziosk does in a restaurant
is pay on demand, right?
You don't have to wait
for your waitstaff
to bring in the
check on the table.
So we're going to show how
that becomes a lot easier
with Android Pay.
So Prakash, you want
to follow through?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Sure.
So I'm going to select Pay.
And all I have to do is tap.
And as you can see, my
Bank of America MasterCard
payment was sent.
And I'm going to--
VIREN BALAR: Hold on.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: I'm going
to select a higher tip because--
VIREN BALAR: Only 5% for Max.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: OK,
so let's go for generous.
And we'll tip this amount.
I'm just going to sign.
And guess what?
For a receipt, I'm just going
to select the email option,
submit, and I'm done-- a
digital dining experience.
VIREN BALAR: Thank you, Prakash.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Thank you, Viren.
OK, so that covered
the user section.
And now I'm going
to turn it over
to Max who's going to talk
about merchants and developers.
MAX KRISTOF: Great,
thank you very much.
So last year we showed
you Save to Android Pay.
We're excited to be announcing
some major enhancements based
on your feedback.
So first, we heard you.
We've added Save to
Android Support directly
from emails and SMS messages.
We're allowing with
these mechanisms
to have brands have a richer
more immersive experience
helping you increase
engagement with your customers.
Let's go back to
that Chili's demo.
You saw that Android Pay
prompted Prakash to sign up
for that loyalty program
and offered to prefill
his data to make it super easy.
How did they build that?
Well, it breaks down
to three easy steps.
Step 1, Chili's set
up a loyalty program
in our merchant console.
That's where they
defined what data
they need to collect to enroll
a new customer-- name, phone,
email address--
that kind of stuff.
And they set up branding for
their program and their card
art.
Next, they made a
few simple changes
to their existing
loyalty sign-up site.
Finally, they wrote
a few lines of code
to generate a Save to
Android Pay deep link.
And at the end of
their sign-up flow,
they just redirect to that link.
Android Pay takes
care of the rest.
And we'll show you what
this looks like in practice.
So the key thing here is
that ultimately, we're
just going to create a link.
And the link will
encode everything in it
that we need to trigger the
Save to Android Pay experience.
So now here's the code.
So this is the start.
You saw that Android Pay
prompted Prakash to sign up.
And where does that
prefill data come from?
Well, their sign-up
web page is going
to receive the prefill
parameters in the URL.
This is just standard
HTTPS get type
of stuff that's
going to be encoded
in there-- HTTPS of course.
Chili's is going to create the
loyalty account in their system
however they would
normally do that.
And then we come
to the fun part.
Chile's going to create
a loyalty object.
Then they're going to turn that
object into a JSON web token.
This gives us a signed,
serialized representation
of that loyalty object.
And, finally, Chili's is
going to generate a deep link
from that token that they can
use for multiple channels.
But let's go deeper.
So this is what the loyal
object creation code looks like.
All we really need from you
is about eight pieces of data,
and we show you how
to plug them in here.
Points, and balance,
your class ID--
this comes up when you
create this loyalty
class in our system, it's
an active loyalty state--
an account ID, a name.
Again, just fairly
boilerplate stuff.
You just drop the code
and the data in here,
and then you build.
And you have your
loyalty object.
So now we're going to turn that
object into the JSON web token.
So this is an expansion of
that second step I showed you.
Again, we have some
simpler boilerplate here.
I'm not going to walk you
through all of this right now,
but you just drop
this in your code.
And at the end of this, you have
a serialized, signed web token.
Finally, the last
part of our code
is to turn that into a Save
to Android Pay deep link.
And this is what the
format of that looks like.
We're going to--
that jwt, the jot,
is that web token-- so we're
going to create the link,
add the token into it,
and that's the Save
to Android Pay deep link.
So to sum up, the first step
was create a loyalty program
in the system.
Second, take the user to
my loyalty sign-up page,
whether triggered from a link,
a transaction confirmation,
a Ziosk terminal, and a Ctag.
Possibilities are endless here.
And the last step of my
loyalty sign-up web page
will simply redirect to
the link when I'm done.
When I redirect to
that link, the link
will activate the Save to
Android Pay user experience.
And in a few instants,
the customer's
going to have her loyalty
card on her phone.
Look how easy that was, and
then you can have chips.
So that's great for getting new
customers signed up, but what
about the ones who've downloaded
my mobile app already?
So the good news is I can
use the same basic approach
to save a loyalty
card into Android Pay
directly from within my app.
We show you a rich preview here
to keep the users in your app.
Here, we're showing
Plenti, a loyalty
partner who has
already implemented
Android Pay with us.
And here's what the
Android code looks
like to save this loyalty card.
It's really the same thing.
I'm going to end up creating a
deep link at the end of this.
I'm going to append my JSON
web token to the end of it,
and I'm just going
to intent over there.
Let's take a closer look
at that link though.
If your Android Pay is already
installed on the phone,
you will immediately invoke the
Save to Android Pay experience.
But what if Android Pay is
not installed on the phone?
The user will simply be
redirected to the place
where to download.
And as soon as the app opens,
the Save to Android Pay
experience will complete.
So a lot of
marketing, of course,
is driven by SMS,
and emails, and we
heard that loud and clear.
So we also made sure that
the Save to Android Pay
experience works great
through these channels.
Here's a look at how that
experience would work with SMS.
You can engage your customers
to save your loyalty cards,
offers, gift cards
directly via text message.
Just create a shortened
version of the same Save
to Android Pay deep
link, and then you
embed the shortened link
into your SMS message.
And then we've built a
first class save experience
from email, as you saw.
But it's the same code
behind the scenes.
You just create that link.
You stick it in your email.
Done.
Finally, I want to
look at gift cards.
Like loyalty cards and offers,
we can make these geotargeted
so that they appear
automatically
when they're
contextually relevant
and when the user
is in your store.
This way, they'll be
reminded they have something
to spend at your store.
There are some differences
here because it's a gift card,
but it is really the
same basic structure.
We're going to
create a gift card.
Notice here that when we're
creating the gift card object,
I've set the type to QR
code as my redemption.
That's if I have one of those
old school QR code readers.
But what if I have a cool
NFC reader in my phone?
Or at my point of sale?
And what if I've integrated
with the Android Pay smart tap
technology?
Well, you could
simply say change
that here-- your redemption
type-- to smart tap.
Then you get the benefits of
automatic redemption over NFC,
complete with authentication
and encryption
to protect the data in transit.
And we're excited that
Walgreens, for example,
has already launched NFC smart
tap for loyalty cards in five
stores in the Bay Area.
And I think as you heard
they'll be rolling out
to 8,000 stores in the next few
months, which is really cool.
So, again, we said the
rest of the parameters--
those just eight pieces
of data to plug in here.
We're going to generate
that JSON web token.
Create a deep link
at the end of this.
This should all be looking
pretty familiar to you now.
And because a
lat-long was entered
at the time of setting
up the gift card
class in the first place
back in that step 1--
the merchant console
set up-- no further work
is required to make these
gift cards automatically
surface when the customer
is in your store.
This helps you drive
engagement and keeps
your brand top of mind.
So this is just a
representative sample
of all the great
merchants that are already
working with us in many
different verticals for loyalty
cards, gift cards, and offers.
So let me hand this back to
Prakash to talk about banks.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: All right.
Thank you, Max.
So issuers of banks are
another key stakeholder for us.
And I'm also thrilled
that many of our partners
are in the audience
like Bank of America,
like Discover, like
American Express.
So I just want to
talk about how we are
solving pain points for banks.
So what do banks want?
Fundamentally, they want
to be "top of wallet."
And what we mean by that
is they want their card
to be used for
every transaction,
whether it's an
in-store transaction,
an in-app transaction, transit,
or an online transaction
on the web.
They also want drive innovative
solutions for their users,
and they want to go beyond
mobile banking in their apps.
They want to be able to enable
their cardholders to use
mobile payments from
their apps, controlling
the branding experience but
without writing millions
of lines of code.
And that's what we're
trying to solve here.
So how are we solving this?
Well, we make it very
easy for banks to add
mobile payments to their app.
And I'll show you the user
experience on the next screen.
But essentially once you
add a card to Android Pay
if you're a bank,
as a bank developer,
it's enabled for payment
in-store, in-app, transit,
online.
And if you want to
know more about online,
we have two sessions on Friday.
One is bringing seamless
checkouts to mobile web,
and the second is turbo
charging app monetization
with Android Pay.
So I'd encourage you to
attend those sessions.
So what does the user
experience look like?
So I have my Discover Card.
I've launched my Discover
mobile banking app.
And I have an option to add my
Discover Card to Android Pay.
And all I have to do is verify
a few details, and I'm done.
That card is added
to Android Pay.
So next time I go
and make a purchase,
I can use that for in-store,
in-app, web, transit,
everything.
And I also have the option
to set it as the default.
So let's go a little bit deeper.
How did all this happen?
It happened because of
this box that you see--
Android Pay API for Issuers.
Now, it takes care of
a lot of the headache
and the pain point I talked
about because we handle
everything from tokenization
with the payment networks,
to generating limited use
keys, to storing them securely
on the phone, to performing
cardholder verification,
to creating these
in-app cryptograms,
to handling the NFC
payment protocols,
and also making sure it's
compatible with the thousands
of Android devices
that we have out there.
And the most important
thing is we do all of this,
but the banks still control
most of the branding and user
experience, as you saw
in the previous slide.
And that's what we're
pretty excited about.
The other thing I want to
echo-- and this was brought up
in the previous
presentation-- was
we're really thrilled
that a number
of top banks around the world
have committed to this vision.
They're very excited about the
Android Pay API for Issuers
and they will be
integrating into Android
Pay from their mobile banking
app over the next few months.
So I'm going to talk
about one more thing,
and I'm going to
turn it over to Max,
and that's about another API
we have for issuers called
Card Messaging.
So in this example, I have
my American Express card.
And I get a really
nice reminder saying
I have offers
expiring soon, and I
should take advantage of that.
So Max, let me turn
this over to you.
MAX KRISTOF: Sure.
Great.
So I want to go back to
the code for a second
and talk about all
that stuff that Prakash
mentioned about how do I get
my card into Android Pay.
This is the code--
startTokenization
TapAndPay.tokenize.
That's pretty much it.
Android Pay is going to
handle everything else.
It's going to invoke that UI
and start a series of activities
that's going to walk the user
through what they need to do,
confirming the card details,
accepting the issuer
terms of service, getting
that token, cryptogram,
all that stuff.
And at the end of
this flow, when
we return from this method,
we're going to be done.
That card will be
set up for payments.
So I didn't have to
worry about any of that
as a developer,
which is awesome.
And I can focus my efforts,
if I were a bank developer,
on building a great
mobile banking app
rather than worrying
about all the plumbing.
So of course, as
Prakash mentioned,
I'd also love it if
people are setting my card
as their default for payments.
So I'll add a method
here to make that happen.
TapAndPay.requestSelectToken.
That's going to pop
up a quick dialog
to confirm that we have
user consent to set
this card as the
default. And now
my card will be used
whenever the user taps.
So there are also
a few other methods
that I'm not showing
here, like how
to query the status of
your card, deleting cards,
and things like that.
But they're all similarly
easy, and it gives you
an idea of how easy it is
to integrate Android pay
into your mobile banking app.
Back to that second thing
that Prakash showed you--
the custom messaging.
So this is a server-side
API that we have.
And the key here is that
with the server-side API,
banks can dynamically
update messaging
in Android Pay that will appear
in the card details view.
What you'll see here is title,
Double points at Whole Foods,
and body.
"Earn double points
at Whole Foods"
or "Enjoy a one-time
bonus of 40,000 miles."
So that message can appear
directly in the Android Pay app
next to that card on
the card details view
through the server-side API.
So it's a great way to
reach out to the customers
and create a more immersive,
engaging experience.
So what's next?
First, we want you to try
out the Save to Android Pay
experience yourselves.
How do you do that?
Go to g.co/paygift
on your phones.
If you do that and you come
over to our office hours, which
are conveniently enough, right
over there at table 1 and 2,
right after the
session at 4 o'clock,
you'll get a free
Android collectible.
So you can try out the Save
to Android Pay experience
yourself, and then tap
and redeem it and see
the whole thing in action.
Second, come talk to us.
So talk to us at
the office hours.
We also have office hours
on Thursday and Friday.
2 o'clock on Thursday, and
2 o'clock also on Friday.
And we'll be happy to answer
any questions of any of the APIs
that you saw here and
tell you all about it.
So finally, we need you.
We need you because
Android Pay is only
as amazing as all of the
uses that you create for it.
So with that, I
think we'll wrap up.
We do have a few minutes
for-- we'll take, I think,
about six questions.
And we'll be able to answer
them right at the mic up here.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
No questions.
Can you please
come up to the mic?
MAX KRISTOF: Yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: When is
Android Pay hitting the gear?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
That's a great question.
So we want to make a great
experience on watches
just like we have on phones.
So all we can say is stay tuned.
We don't have timelines to
be able to publicly release.
But you're going to see the same
great experience on the watches
like you're seeing
on the phones.
MALE SPEAKER: I have a
question about data passing.
And so there was a bunch of
examples where there was data
that you had moving from
Android Pay to the device
to apply it, and vice versa,
from an app to Android Pay.
Is there additional permissions
that need to be granted?
Or what data is allowed
to go back and forth
between those two?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Sure, I think as you
saw first, user's consent.
So users make a choice.
And as you saw, when I was
signing up for loyalty,
it prepopulated the information,
but I had to explicitly consent
before it was sent
over to Chili's.
So essentially, it's like--
as you saw in that example--
it was a name, email,
and other information
that I consented to.
MALE SPEAKER: Is that infinite?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: That's
for the loyalty use case.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And is
that consent required,
like if you don't have
a pin set up otherwise?
Does it still prompt
you for consent?
MAX KRISTOF: Sorry, the
question was is it required?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So if you-- you have
a lot of users that
just don't secure their phones.
So if I walked up and
just swiped my phone
and it asked for PII, would it
be granted without my consent
if I didn't already
have a pin set up?
MAX KRISTOF: OK.
Yeah, so there are two
different issues here.
One is before we transmit
any PII to a merchant,
to a loyalty sign-up
page, for example,
we absolutely show that
box no matter what.
And you absolutely have
to click OK, Yes I Agree.
And if the user
doesn't click I Agree,
they can still be taken to
the loyalty sign-up page.
It's just the form will
be blank and they'll
have the joy of entering
all that data themselves
on a lovely mobile keyboard.
The second part of
the question, though,
is Android Pay and screen locks.
So Android Pay does require,
as part of its setup,
a screen lock.
And that's fingerprint,
pin, pattern, password.
Those are the recognized
secure screen locks
that are required
to use Android Pay.
MALE SPEAKER: In a few countries
is supported Android Pay?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Yeah, so I think
what we have publicly
I think-- just
so I understand your question.
You're asking for countries
where we support Android Pay
or where are going?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Are you
referring a certain country?
MALE SPEAKER: South America.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
OK, South America.
So I think I want to echo
what was said earlier.
Our aspiration is for
Android Pay to be everywhere
Android is.
But a journey's going
to take a few steps.
So what we've publicly
announced is the UK, of course,
and Australia, and
Singapore, besides the US.
So we are looking constantly
at other countries,
and you're going to see more
announcements going forward.
That's all I can say.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, thank you.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: No
more questions, huh?
MAX KRISTOF: We have time
for two more questions.
Otherwise, we'll be happy to
talk to you in a more intimate
setting out at the office hours.
By the way, at the
office hours, we'll
have several members of
our team there as well
who can really kind of deep
dive into any of these areas.
Yes?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do
you plan to have
Android Pay inside
of [INAUDIBLE] auto
for payments from
inside the car?
MAX KRISTOF: Payments
in the car, Prakash,
what do you think?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So again,
we're looking at all use cases
to make it a great
user experience.
We can't get into specifics
about dates and times.
MAX KRISTOF: OK.
Looks like there's
one more question.
Please come up to the mic.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
the devel you showed
as specific tab-based
POS terminals, right?
So what happens to MSD-based?
Like merchants with
MSD-based terminals?
MAX KRISTOF: Yeah,
and the question
is about loyalty cards?
Or?
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Regular payments.
MAX KRISTOF: Regular
payments, right.
So at the moment, for
in-store experience,
we require contactless
technology support.
For loyalty gift card
offers, we have a variety
of different redemption methods,
including bar codes, QR codes,
as well as, of course, NFC.
I think we're big
believers in NFC,
and we've really seeing great
traction in the ecosystem.
There's a lot of
re-terminalization happening
right now at merchants.
And we know this is
a journey, but it
looks like the journey
is in progress.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
All right, I think
we're going to wrap it up.
So thank you again
for coming, and don't
forget to come to office hours
like we mentioned earlier.
And enjoy the rest of IO.
MAX KRISTOF: Thank you.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]